yeah welcome to this new five minute
game against Grand Master Gorham um who
is this snow named okay so let's see we
probably get a King's Indian play all
kinds of Florence
h3s one of them
yeah this is some a line that is played
sometimes tending b5 not quite quite
sure about the best answer I just went
with normal development 5
it's a bit curious I mean you can really
win the porn but I thought why not I
mean you really get it back so easily
now yeah okay with with with moves like
g5 yeah what's this it's just just a
crap for black it's got its color he's a
porn down and it's full of weaknesses
okay so how to how to play now it's not
threatening anything special the
question is how to organize pieces maybe
you keep on there just in protecting the
opponent maybe I'm giving this this
bishop a place on f1 if needed
yeah the further prophecy is so weakened
here I cannot cannot really move
anything night cannot go to the seventh
for example my idea now is supply even
before trying to fix the weaknesses
okay I'd like to play a three and before
if possible okay this cannot be I cannot
be so bad or any
this is senseless Belgium should have
kept control over over age five I hope
I'm not losing my material and now
yeah in fact I do talk about talk about
I know babe FFP should be too this is
does there's some unknown explain before
even yeah this was just I mean again
okay is there some some way to to get
get some play out of this I mean I just
blended this piece basically
I can take here
I'm not I didn't blunder peace but
really really totally unnecessary to get
him give him any sort of play and he has
got a bit of planer
and everybody to Quincy three it's just
just holding
yeah this is weak square
probably no way to continue without that
well I'm not sure the deep on it's not
clear how to see how does he proceed now
yeah but I have I have Queen a5 Bishop
d3 ideas now he's got a Wii King I think
the worst is over I mean in terms of
initiative by black at least I hope that
look where our C 1 or D 3 F 3 is this is
this is an idea I cannot I cannot spend
so much time maybe you can play queen
bee one now or this one is also not bad
okay go here prepare rook F 3 at the
tech age 6
rook f3 he's got rook f1 unbelievable
yeah no no way you're around that yeah I
saw that but what else
time warning
check
yeah this was just a terrible game I
mean what what I mean okay he five is
just double question mark and winning
straight of the bed here and now I'm
playing is really so terrible that he
gets back into the game
yeah this is maybe you know this this is
just just bad yeah and just I forgot
about the h5 square I need to control h5
yeah well besides stuff like computer
moves yeah 95 he resigns immediately
computer gives that yeah mines not even
some so difficult to figure out actually
but okay not in the Blitz game can I can
put it on the board so if he takes here
the others Bishop Bishop c7s there's the
problem
like Knight moves Bishop c7 and the
queen is trapped so let's say here just
for example then there's this move
Bishop c7 and the rook also here yeah
this is the the just way to end this
game but 95 okay it's a blitz game that
cannot spend all day but Queen f3 is
just good controlling h5 yes no move
simply nothing to pawn down and full of
weaknesses I forgot about the h5 square
so he had this takes takes this is just
just bad of course again I have 95 he
just I I was so irritated I thought I I
lose a piece with this but I have had
this smooth
instead he played before which which
losses due to this move again
yeah I was so shocked about overlooking
that drives that I didn't didn't think
about this yeah it's very nautical move
even that look a look at this position I
mean yeah and all our pieces I just
grabbed plus seven as this computer okay
I took him and then I took I took him I
took on v8 sorry
yeah this is just just the terrible game
full of bad news
and here I'm better again of course yeah
there are only saw it here the smooth so
route III is probably nonsense this
should be too with the clear advantage
yeah well this is computer moves it's
difficult in one minute something but um
would be - Quincy - yeah this is
annoying I didn't see that it's it's an
immediate made threat yeah like
immediate made no I saw it but it's no
way I have no way to prevent this I
cannot kind of move back or something
and yeah this was a game that actually
both players should lose yeah thanks for
watching